Speaker 1: Welcome to the show.
It's great to be back.
I know I'm tan, please, no emails about me
being tan.
I wore sunscreen, I did all of it.
We had a lot of major, major news events during
the period that I was gone.
Farin and Jesse did a really great job of
staying on top of everything for you.
And I want to start today with the most requested
segment over the last 72 hours, which was
people coming to me and saying, David, sir,
please tell us what you think about what's
going on in Afghanistan now.
As many of you who have been with the show
for a while may remember, you may not, but
you may that we'll find out soon.
You might remember that I talked about the
Afghanistan withdrawal when Donald Trump planned
to do it and announced that he was doing it.
And I talked about it again when Joe Biden
announced, hey, that pause we put on Trump's
Afghanistan withdrawal.
We've evaluated it and we are going to do
it.
And it's going to happen by September 11th.
President Joe Biden is now being widely criticized
for his actions in Afghanistan, which are
carrying out the plan to remove troops that
Donald Trump and Republicans bragged about
and cheered for for months during the end
of Donald Trump's presidency.
Now, that's not me starting to say, well,
I'm going to blame here or there.
It's just the reality.
What Biden did was to go forward with more
or less the plan that Donald Trump announced
and that Trump cheered and that Trump cheered
predictably, just like we said a few months
ago, whether it was Trump leaving or Biden
leaving, it would cause chaos.
But at a certain point, our responsibility
has to end because our involvement has been
a disaster.
Staying longer won't solve anything.
The Afghanistan intervention failed.
And it's really important in these cases when
people start saying, oh, we left the wrong
way or we did, OK, we can talk about that.
But at a certain point, our involvement had
to end.
Even though Biden is sending 6000 troops back
in now, which we'll get to.
And it was going to be a fiasco whenever it
ended.
Those things were essentially the they were
certain, regardless of which president was
in the Oval Office when this happened, so
we could stay and keep failing or we could
leave the vacuum when we left, as was worldwide
news earlier this week, immediately led to
the Taliban taking over and then all sorts
of different hot takes.
Joe Biden left the wrong way.
We do have to ensure the safety of our people
and to be empathetic when it comes to refugees
that we I am on board by saying there should
have been better advance action to prevent
some of what we saw there.
But unfortunately, a lot of it was essentially
inevitable.
As we said months ago, the same people, pro
Trump Republicans who now are ignoring that
Donald Trump had the same plan, are starting
to say this would have been totally different
if it had been managed by a different president.
Actually, no, it wouldn't have been.
And there are some Trump acts as well as people
on the left who just don't like Joe Biden,
who are now saying, well, the vacuum allowed
the Taliban to take over and we didn't do
enough to get our people, other people, refugees
out in time.
If we had done the get people out in time
part, do you think those people would be satisfied?
No, those very same people would just be focusing
on the Taliban took over and we would be seeing
the exact same reactions from those people.
And sadly, there are tons of bad faith actors
on both sides on this issue.
Now, I'm not saying the same number of people
on both sides.
I would be called out for playing the both
sides game if I did that.
But there are bad faith actors on both sides
right now.
You have people on the right saying terrible
decision by Joe Biden when Trump was going
to do this, it was going to be totally different.
No, Trump would have done it in the exact
same way.
Don't let them lie and say Trump had some
master plan for preventing what happened.
Trump had no master plan for anything.
The idea that he would have had such a plan
for Afghanistan is absolutely absurd.
Trump would have done the exact same thing.
And by the way.
All the references to this being Trump's plan
all along suddenly removed from the GOP website,
Trump's websites within hours of this going
down in Afghanistan, all of those references
to Trump's plan to get out of Afghanistan,
deal with the Taliban, etc.
It's a bold faced attempt to revise history.
Then the left saying this is the typical centrist
Democrat foreign policy of Joe Biden.
You go in for the wrong reasons and then you
cut and run.
Well, hold on a second.
George W. Bush is responsible for us being
there, not Joe Biden, not Donald Trump and
not Barack Obama.
There is not nearly enough discussion of George
W. Bush here.
And I think that, you know, if you go to a
bad dentist and the dentist screws up your
tooth.
And then you go to other dentists and the
first dentist that tries to fix it doesn't
do a great job, and then you go to a third
dentist and that dentist basically gets you
out of harm's way.
You're not going to have an abscess, but the
tooth is going to hurt for several months.
We talk about what the third dentist wasn't
able to do.
We talk about how the second dentist messed
up the repair.
But what started it was that first dentist
who messed up your tooth.
And there is not nearly enough discussion
to use a dental analogy of George W. Bush
in the Bush administration's role here.
There's a lot of Biden versus Trump stuff.
At some point, someone had to say what George
W. Bush started can go no further, no more
money into this.
No more contractors getting rich.
The contractors mostly out of Afghanistan
over recent months because the withdrawal
was coming that with the contractors.
We've got to stop that as well.
And Joe Biden's speech to the nation on Monday,
it wasn't satisfying to a lot of people who
emailed me, but it was fundamentally an honest
speech.
And by honest, I mean, it's the type of honesty
we don't usually get from politicians.
It was one of the most honest political speeches
by a president in a long time.
And it was completely decisive.
It was we had to do it.
We had to do it.
As I tweeted earlier this week, quote, So
you stay another year to leave correctly,
simply delaying what happened by a year, enriching
more contractors who would go back in.
And so then what?
The same thing happens in 2022.
At some point you have to cut your losses.
And Joe Biden's speech was decisive and Joe
Biden was the guy to do it.
And he takes responsibility for what took
place after.
Now, if there is anything to really criticize
there, it's well, now 6000 troops are going
back in to help people get out and restabilize,
which we could say is going backwards.
You pull out the last fifteen hundred chaos
ensues and you sends that 6000 back in.
So I'm not saying it's wrong to try to help
grease the exit in some way.
That's not my criticism.
But in a sense, are we really even doing it?
If 6000 are going back and the devil really
is in the details with what those 6000 are
going to be doing and we will get back and
we'll dig into that further probably later
this week.
But you know what?
It had to be done.
You don't tend to see this level of decisive
action on foreign policy combined with just
telling it like it is.
And so I think for that, you have to give
Biden credit and then we figure out which
aspects of it could have been better managed.
I